again i get harassed yo david gets
bullied everywhere he goes
what the [ __ ] is it about me that
everybody feels like they could harass
me leave in the comments below why do
you think david gets bullied so much or
why do people choose to disrespect him
so hard to space the level of disrespect
that i always get at a gym specifically
it's like you don't belong here
[Laughter]
the [ __ ] disrespect so first of all
when i go
who this guy is i don't want to see him
i don't even go to work out anymore i
just hit the sign
in five four three two one hello
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast we got the
[ __ ] crew back today we got stranger
things pack going on here
ready to get molested in the 80s what it
is what it is is that the plot is that
what happens
that's all the show's about yeah that
demon comes and just but i'd be licking
licking asses and hating remember
stranger things at all it's good it's
really got anybody getting less i don't
think shut up
there's a i remember the first season
being really good but then after that i
didn't watch this it's all the same [ __ ]
it's the monster comes back and then
they're like oh they're about to die and
they get saved by the government that's
negative huh i know this guy did but
it's fun along the way though history
has representation now yeah
one little [ __ ] in there everybody's
like happy as hell he see everything i'm
into it dude you're into it like you
guys [ __ ] hear about the jake paul
fight yeah
getting his [ __ ]
i just feel like he's going to let us
down once again i really do i'm just
like yeah negative over here yeah i'm
rubbing up on you he's going to let us
down i just have a feeling that i don't
say that dude i mean i don't want him to
obviously i'd like it if he knocked him
out but i just the way he fights he's
too he's too conservative okay so dylan
dennis he went on i think some
interviews and was saying that goomba
yeah the goomba
he was saying how um there's a clause in
the fight potentially of tyron woodley
not being able to knock out jake paul
you think that's true
i mean if that's true it kind of makes
sense because after he cracked him he
just kind of stalked him yeah didn't do
anything it was just odd right there was
a clause saying tyron would they could
not knock him out yeah yeah which i and
dylan dana said this bro he was
negotiating both parties he was the bob
arum of this transaction dylan danis was
yeah he's he's a manager
people barely
i wonder if that's true because that
fight because i saw him chase that was
the part where i was screaming i was
like knock him out and he just kind of
just didn't do anything yeah so that
would make sense because it was just so
weird and i feel like there's money to
be made for both of them and it's it's
kind of in tyrone woodley's best
interest if there's some weird stuff
like that happens
you know and then there's a potential
for another fight because he kind of it
kind of worked out in the way if he
loses to jake paul two times in a row i
said it's just
everything that he has done in his
career is over disappeared yeah
disappeared nobody gives a [ __ ] anymore
so you lost to a [ __ ] youtuber that
boxed for three years like twice twice
two times
i'd kill myself how about that huh
that first match was [ __ ] frustrating
so if he comes back and he knocks him
the [ __ ] out like in the second round
give him a [ __ ] ufc belt again you
know the heavyweight time honorary belt
i don't give a [ __ ] what it is i
actually don't
particularly want jake paul to lose
though yeah i don't i don't wish
anything bad upon him i just like tyron
woodley that much so
i want him to win i want to see him get
a w at least or just to redeem himself
because like
that's so sad to say that though that he
has to redeem himself against jake paul
but he has a second chance he got a
second shot at it
that's the crazy part whoever thought he
was i didn't think they were going to
fight again did you think that jake paul
would beat uh tommy fury or the other
way around no no i i've actually never
seen tommy fairy box but i saw him box
at that same match that they boxed when
tyron woodley was boxing sure i guess
i think like technique-wise he's a lot
cleaner right i mean obviously he's a
[ __ ] fury right yeah but he's not
that great either from from the looks of
it because they both just started they
actually have similar boxing experience
in terms of years of fighting pro so i
think they both are on par that's why
that fight was actually pretty exciting
yeah because they had similar levels and
similar victories and similar wins
they're both quote-unquote undefeated
differences that tommy ferry actually
fought real boxers he's like 7-0 or
something yeah he has a pretty good
record compared to
jake paul who's only fought like
the most random people have ever i would
just imagine anybody that really boxes
will beat jake paul yeah that's why i
was just like yeah i'm sure this guy
tales sudden loves jake paul though he
says he's the real [ __ ] deal chael
sanders killed sonnen wow smoke
has not predicted a fight well in the
last 30 years he's the kiss of death
yeah if he says you're gonna win you'll
usually lose yeah right everyone's like
oh [ __ ] uncle picked someone so did you
hear what their [ __ ] what uh tommy
fury and what's what's their dad's name
i don't know is it i thought it was
tyson
i mean tyson fury's dad what's her dad's
name i thought it was just tyson too i
thought he was like a tyson tyson like
his first name is tyson tyson
john john
furrier so john fury was saying that
if
if tommy lost to jake paul that he was
going to retire himself he goes he will
never be allowed to box again i think
that's fair
crazy that is crazy he's he's a part of
like a legendary family
he's a gypsy boxing gypsies yeah so if
he loses to [ __ ] jake paul that's
like a you'd have to yeah i appreciate
yeah i appreciate that 100 yeah if you
lose to this youtuber youtuber yeah if
you lose to this boom this youtuber he
said he was gonna [ __ ] retire him and
he was dead ass seriously if you lose to
this guy your [ __ ] career is done i
will never allow you to box he's gonna
sacrifice him dude to the woods to the
forest or
think about that though like tommy fury
and i'm sure like you know you could
reinvent yourself [ __ ] yeah i was gonna
say like look at uh tyson fury and then
look at that full like i would say
completely different bodies too how are
they related they both have the longest
arms half yeah half siblings different
moms i think so yeah for sure i'll get
john fury huh slang in it
i'm trying to see what tommy fury's mom
looks like i mean libido is also fury
just coming in everybody homes whatever
youtubers but if he's an up-and-coming
boxer and he loses to a youtuber and
he's fighting real boxers yeah that
that's the second
career and i'm sure he could reinvent
himself but he's always gonna be the guy
that's like oh that's the guy that lost
a [ __ ] jake paul that's a rap but
unless unless he has a crazy prolific
career afterwards because the only the
only thing that makes sense now is that
like i said their careers are the
trajectory is kind of similar and then
on top of that he's actually the same
size yeah for the first time he's gonna
box somebody that's his size true
similar reach maybe even longer who
knows and now he has to deal with bigger
opponents yeah and then you know you
have [ __ ] tommy fury who's probably
also sparring his brother who's a
[ __ ] giant right he looks like a
pacman long no torso [ __ ] long ass
limbs and [ __ ]
so i'm i wonder who broke his ribs
because so he had a chest infection and
he also had a fractured rib [ __ ] that's
why he had to pull out
it's a doozy bro which is kind of hard
because he's he was talking a lot of
[ __ ] he goes i he goes i wish you would
pull out if you [ __ ] pull out you're
a [ __ ] yeah he's the one who had to so
he has to deal with those comments now
which by the way is kind of hard to
[ __ ] swallow yeah because people are
[ __ ] on him right now yeah but what
are you gonna do you're injured you're
injured you know broken ribs is pretty
rough tell sonny says it's not a big
deal though that's what he said really
he was like it's not a big deal to have
broken ribs people have fought through
that [ __ ] but i'm like i don't know yeah
i do not know he lost the title ortiz i
think you should probably shut down
you got guilty by him yeah i say that
somebody was never fought in this life
but you're a little [ __ ]
yeah bro
i'm kidding i love children
that's cool
he's the original colby covington he is
he's the one that started it all he did
at the highest level he started the
trash talk yeah he started it he started
he was the guy nobody else did
everything anderson silva you absolutely
suck
he was the best at [ __ ] talking hands
down so good did he [ __ ] talk brazil
yeah yeah so he was like you guys are
all [ __ ] filthy something like he was
going
like the american kids are playing like
on the playground and you look over and
there's like brazilian kids playing in
the mud like all sad and [ __ ]
he was like
this is like on the spot yeah he would
just go he was going for that's pretty
good yeah what did he say
ortiz that was about his wife oh yeah
something about uh second two something
about sucking something about making
money on their back or sucking oh yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
and tina was like bro he was stuttering
what are you gonna say yeah he got
nothing to say your wife suck dick on
camera
the most famous also the most famous to
do it yeah that's true that's how good
she was like oh gee right just jameson
he's married to jenna jameson
i think they've obviously had problems
and she's crazy and yeah i think he has
custody of the kids that's how bad she
was oh jenna jameson's nuts huh yeah she
was like she's poor she's probably one
of the like classically pretty porn
people ever yeah but there was the
original that was the era of like blonde
porn stars with big old tits like that
was that was the heyday there's no like
porn mega stars anymore anybody can do
porn now anybody could there's like like
like i guess the ones that pop right but
like not like that you're right it's not
the same thing like that she was like a
cultural icon
a billionaire she actually made a
business off of everything i thought
yeah she be i forgot which company it
was but it's actually in los angeles but
i heard she was like became a big
executive or she owns it now it was like
the biggest porn company ever before you
know pornhub and all the the free porn
came out but she was like top-tier [ __ ]
so she took her porn career and actually
did made a really great business out of
it so smart dude so who knows and i
gotta tell you
i don't like i don't like what's his
name tito so i'm pretty sure it's tito's
fault dude
he was the mayor of huntington beach
that's so crazy which is the weirdest
thing ever yeah how the [ __ ] did he win
how did that happen he's the huntington
peach bad boy bro who else are they
going to have as mayor is that his
actual nickname yeah that's fun remember
with the with the fire on the tight on
the shorts ugh i remember sometimes back
in the day when this is back when we
were training together like early like
2010 ish we there was a guy that would
always come in the gym or there was
multiple people that come to the gym
with the t or t shorts oh my god 100
chance that they were always [ __ ]
[ __ ]
like they just were so [ __ ] i'm
surprised ortiz didn't come out with a
[ __ ] white pillow case over his head
he's [ __ ]
white ass mexican he loves white people
so much
mexican
yeah i guess he is racial draft he's
[ __ ] on the white on the white side
the whites are picking i think so
huntington beach huntington beach bad
boy that might be one of the whitest
[ __ ] towns of all time you know yeah
it's up there it's pretty it's okay
i [ __ ] miss watching like the old
ufc's though i was watching they put all
the old classic clips they would just
football kick each other in the [ __ ]
face yeah it was brutal it was so brutal
bad dude who's the the
the first one where the sumo dude lost
his tooth yeah the hawaiian dude and it
just flew out the [ __ ] cage
no no there's like a skinny white dude
in gee pants right yeah this guy kicks
his like huge samoan dude in the face
and uh that it was like the first fight
ever and they were like all right enough
did i remember i used to they used to
have the old ufc's in blockbuster like
this is back in the day like ultimate
knockouts right i was like ken shamrock
on with like lightning bolts behind him
on the cover
and i rented it i got my dad to rent it
and uh we i took it to my aunt's house
and there was like a family party going
on i was like let's watch this
and i put it on and everyone was
horrified oh my god
it's like ah and it had that knockout it
had like a bunch of i think it had like
some crazy ken shamrock ones it had one
where the dude's just punching the guy
in the balls yes that was the thought
thing that shocked me the most i
completely forgot that ball strikes were
allowed yeah bring that back but there's
a guy who had like side mount and he was
just crushing his sucking balls straight
up and the fool was fine it was the dude
from uh austin powers remember there was
like an asian dude and he had like a hat
yeah yeah it was that guy getting his
balls destroyed by some [ __ ]
technique i think it was actually that
guy that guy actually fought funny you
ever seen those asian news that that
like the shaolin monks that just take
all the ball kicks like what's the point
of that bro hey don't ask asian that's
mental strength
the dk [ __ ]
do you know who the dku is oh
he's the korean version of the detroit
urban survival tactic training that guy
he's like the chinese version uh korean
but is he serious okay so because the
dku the other guy's joking right
now because i saw one where he's
definitely he's out of the joke yeah
well he's not a joke but that's his
actual business he's for real there's
one where the guy dies and goes to
heaven yeah yeah
yeah yeah he's like always going to be
trying to train he's right you got to go
to your training bro you can't just
learn one move and think you're good you
got to train that [ __ ] okay wait who's
this
dku is a south korean instructor that
kind of developed his own fighting style
so people were kind of calling him like
the rebirth of bruce lee right so he's
taking all these different type of
modalities
and creating his own uh fighting style
right so he uses one specifically that i
didn't really know about which is called
systema system is like a russian
military and they kind of use like this
weird whipping form where
yeah it's you keep your body loose so i
i literally had to read this up because
i couldn't stop giggling watching people
do this so it's the essential thing is
like when you hit something like a whip
and i'm not sure this is not exactly
from a wikipedia thing i read it from
somebody else's comment and write it
question translation and it was from
somebody who bought his um
his instruction instructional [ __ ] guess
who else bought it jojo's a car so he
didn't buy it he did it he was telling
us about it and so not in a funny way
like he actually bought he's like yo
there's some good [ __ ] in there yeah so
like you know when you when you whip
somebody with the whip right the
strongest point is at the tail end right
the snap right so that essentially is
what these punches mimic so
he'll do something where he'll whip his
arm so you keep your body really loose
just to conserve energy yeah the end
point is when you strike really hard
like a whip so he does
and so you kind of watch these videos
like when i first watched it i was
pretty amazed how fast he was okay right
so oh this guy is really [ __ ] quick
but it's the most ridiculous [ __ ] it's
like he'll hit you like 10 times really
soft and then somebody will grab him
he'll shoulder bump this person off and
they'll fly away oh okay so dku
a lot of people [ __ ] with dku a lot as a
korean person
i love you
as a human being what the [ __ ] man
he's 42 years old decides to go do a
boxing match with a 30 he was in the ufc
apparently yeah he wasn't like the
ultimate fighter i think he fought the
ultimate fighter which first of all he's
if you saw a picture of him he's 32 he
looks like he's 70. he looks like [ __ ]
and he outweighed him by like 20 pounds
oh way more than that
you outweighed the
the other way he's a british guy his
name is like bradley scott i think yeah
bradley scott so he was actually in the
ufc and he he could strike he got nice
hands actually like i was i was looking
through his instagram the other day and
he was like boxing and stuff and he was
like doing showing some sparring rounds
he's like one of those british guys that
just are really into boxing like he's
really technical hands like he was
pretty good he's a big guy he
does not look anything like how he did
in the ufc he gained like 40 pounds lost
all of his hair he's bald
he looked older than dku and dku is 10
years older than him so he's a 42 year
old versus a 32 year old and he
outweighs him by at least 40 pounds damn
and so dku took on this match one of the
most embarrassing things i've ever seen
in my life it was bad it was
horrendous you fall on the
[Music]
yeah but it was it was just hella goofy
bro like it just wasn't a good look like
did the english dude crack him
tried his best i mean dku is
he's he's oh what's the word he's um
a loose he's a charlatan squirrel get
the [ __ ] off me yeah yeah he'll wiggle
around you you know what i mean it
looked like he didn't want to be in the
exchanges it was wiggling well he was
doing this his stuff that he does in his
videos where he kind of flicks out his
hands but as we all know when you flick
somebody in the face what damage does it
really do besides sting yeah it doesn't
do [ __ ] so he's doing his hands down
thing the systema type of like whipping
arm [ __ ] and so the way he throws his
jab he kind of lunges forward and he
whips it out he's a lot of energy
and i guess you kind of you kind of tap
him a little bit but she's just gonna
walk right through that [ __ ] right
he's way bigger he's way bigger
yeah it was the low velocity there wow
and i heard he was making excuses too
after about why what was he saying
i don't know how did it end in korean or
some [ __ ] i just stopped i heard the
commentators were really biased like
anything he would do they were all like
oh my god he's he's still in it like
they were hyping him up i think they had
to because he was getting his ass well
of course because it's a south korean
promotion though yeah it was a south
korean promotion but i feel like they
had to do that because if they don't
it's just them making fun of them the
whole time
you know because that's cool too yeah i
mean it just is what it is
it was bad dude damn i gotta watch this
we should they should just do a systema
match is there such thing they just do
that i don't like when these like dku
i'm he shouldn't be boxing anybody he's
fast i'll give him that did it end his
range of motion his punches like this
yeah that's what i'm just saying i gotta
say nice things because you know korea
never lose
so he won that fight oh he definitely
won dude
in the korean community's eyes he won
dude yeah that was it yeah he fought a
guy that was 500 pounds more than him
yeah
was it decision or did he get stopped
i don't i think it was a decision but
honestly i you know i want to say
i want to say the ufc guy pulled back
but i don't think he did either i think
the that dude was also
tired as well because he was really out
of shape
you know he was tr i saw his uh his
match in the ufc he's actually a jujitsu
guy really yeah he's not a striking dude
at all whatsoever so when you kind of
looked at his striking even in there i
thought his boxing was gonna be better
than what it actually was yeah the
videos i saw i was like he's boxing's
pretty nice did you see the actual fight
though
he was doing great body shots i saw i
saw one combination and that was enough
for me to be like i was good
i was like i was like oh he that's all i
have to see yeah because i heard the
fight wasn't even that good like it was
just dk kind of running around and it
was like a rock fight he was like
fumbling he was falling to the floor so
he kept on trying to do like front rolls
of [ __ ] front roll so he was like trying
to body lock him but he would just chuck
him off put his weight on him throw him
off frame him off and he would just fly
and roll to the floor saying like he
punched me in the back of the head it's
like bro i thought you were the ultimate
guy yeah right he was supposed to fight
somebody else wasn't he dku you were
supposed to fight the chinese dude that
beats up everybody yeah he beats up all
those poor tai chi masters yeah like
damn bro
it made more sense
that fight would have made more sense i
just i just don't like this like i get
it bro these these kung fu masters a lot
of them are all charlatans and they're
teaching people nonsense
but like they're also 70 years old and
this [ __ ] yeah this thick ass
chinese mma fighter hey power to you bro
he's just whooping everybody's ass
the [ __ ] this is elder abuse bro he
started asian hate he said
he's not around beating up all these old
chinese let me show you americans how to
really [ __ ] up asian people
and it's like yeah they know tai chi and
they know like they're [ __ ] they're
kooky ass uh martial arts that don't
work but i'm like
you know it don't work you really gotta
go and [ __ ] like the uh the chat with
their nose
because his his main goal i forgot what
his name is but
he kind of thought him
his main thing is that he's trying to
show that all this kung fu wizardry is
not real right but the thing about that
stuff is also embedded into culture and
these dudes it's different context
first of all tai chi is like a
meditative thing right and you know
these tai chi masters are saying that
they could beat up anybody but they're
also like 60 years old let them say what
they want yeah they're all kooks
everybody knows they're not gonna beat
up anybody so what's the point of this
[ __ ] it's like when your grandparents
say crazy [ __ ] you're gonna correct them
every single time you know how
exhausting that is it's just like you
gotta let them just say they're [ __ ]
because they're old and it's kind of
funny though out of date but he's just
not gonna [ __ ]
he's like their own [ __ ] same
team man
that old [ __ ] they just let him
loose in the retirement home he's just
beating the [ __ ] out of everybody
kickboxing gym and he got [ __ ] up for
sure so he went to you know he does his
mma stuff he's not that great of a
fighter like he's he's a wild boy he's a
little bit below average at best dude
that's why you gotta beat up all these
old chinese people that was a
disappointing thing too for it's like
you're not even that great yourself at
your moment bully you're a bully i don't
like that [ __ ] that's true so
he goes into a [ __ ] muay thai
kickboxing gym right these
guys like the way he [ __ ] up those old
guys those guys [ __ ] him up damn
flying knees grabbing the back of head
kneeing his face in he was bleeding from
his mouth like i think i saw that clip
actually
it's literally 10 minutes of him getting
murdered wow what's like four people
what's his name some chinese i'm chinese
a destroyer
destroyer yeah he's over here just
giving [ __ ] uh 70 year old cte
let me tell you this dude
[ __ ] south pass gym again i get
harassed yo david gets bullied
everywhere he goes
what the [ __ ] is it about me that
everybody feels like they can harass me
leave in the comments below why do you
think david gets bullied so much or why
do people choose to disrespect him so
hard to his face the level of disrespect
that i always get at a gym specifically
it's like you don't belong here
[Laughter]
the [ __ ] disrespect so first of all
who this guy is i don't want to see him
i don't even go to work out anymore i
just hit the sauna
i'm just known as the sonic guy hey wait
until that juice bar opens up david just
going to be chilling he's going to be mr
juice
after i saw him guess what i do i'll
give me a kombucha
but so so when you go to this gym they
have a dedicated sonnet that you have
the book ahead of time right now
when you book this there's a double
confirmation so you book the time slot
and then you say book to confirm that's
how you get it so i go to the gym
it's my sonnet time right because it's
time for me to work out go to the gym to
hit the sauna
get inside there that's a noise and i
see
and i see a guy wearing one of those
little swiss suits sweaty sweatsuits
right
sweatsuits yeah you know like five foot
eight five foot nine wide dude and i
knock on the door tap tap tap tap very
nice he can say it's a see-through it
says it's a glass but you're like and i
and i open and i'm like hey brother i
booked the 115 to two and it's also a
120 right yeah and then the [ __ ] out of
you and i closed the door by the way i i
showed up like around 1 30. so i was
already 15 minutes late so i just closed
it
and then he comes out and when he comes
out he [ __ ] swings the door at me
like
so he's the reason why the door is
broken so
oh boom opens up i'm like i kind of
moved back you go so you just turn the
[ __ ] sauna off on me first of all
number one swung the door at me don't
curse at me yeah he said
[ __ ] sauna so now it's like oh that's
aggressive he's mad at me yeah and so
i'm stopping i look at him i'm like hey
just to let you know i can't turn off
the sauna the controls are on the inside
yeah yeah you call it those [ __ ]
idiot afterwards and so he was like yeah
so you just turn that [ __ ] off on me
cursed hit me twice now i'm already
pissed and i'm like hey i don't think
you know how this works
i can't turn off the sauna and i said it
just like that the controls are on the
inside so there's a timer
if it turned off it probably turned out
because it's just a coincidence that
right when you open the door it just
turned off i was like guy what don't you
understand i physically can't there are
no controls on the outside i started
pointing at the box i was like look
where where's the buttons there's a
control panel that controls it
and i grabbed the remote this is for the
light you can't turn it off and so he
just kind of sits down
i'm like whatever and i go inside the
[ __ ] sun is cold he didn't turn on
the sauna he was sitting in there for 20
minutes with the sauna off in a sauna
suit idiot dumbass so now i'm even more
mad yeah yeah cause the sun is cold yeah
and as a courtesy at this gym you should
always turn on the sauna ahead of time
yeah because [ __ ] be turning
that [ __ ] off yeah and you got to leave
it you got to pay it forward to the next
person so by the time they get in there
it's already 150 true so this [ __ ]
idiot i think i'll let it cook and i'm
getting more so i sit there i walk
outside i was like hey let me show you
something real quick
and i turned the thing on it's at 110
degrees you were sitting in a cold sauna
[ __ ] you didn't even turn the sauna
on you were in room temp below room temp
dog i was like
80 degrees bruh i was like he was just
didn't he didn't say anything i was like
yeah moted he got blown is not you
didn't even turn it on you sat in a cold
sauna for 20 minutes he probably thought
he was getting good work too
i got the sauna suit on like this is
like the sauna
and and then he sat there and this is
the thing too he just goes yeah whatever
and i was like hey hold on a second yeah
[ __ ] you dude let's break this guy's
legs so there's like people watching at
this point there's like a couple people
watching because i'm getting a little
[ __ ] angry hey let me ask you
something are you [ __ ] mad at me and
he was like nah we're good i was like no
no no you're mad at me why are you mad
at me what did i do to you for you to be
mad yeah because clearly i didn't touch
anything you're actually in my time slot
he goes well we probably got double
booked i was like fine if we got double
booked is that my fault and is that
right for you to get mad at me is that
okay for you to act the way that you're
acting yeah and he was like nah it's
cool i'm good i'm good i was like no
it's not i'm good i'm not good i was
like you [ __ ] swung the door at me
and now you're giving me a [ __ ]
attitude because you don't know how to
use this machine because you're stupid
yeah yeah so i was like so are we good
now you're right we're fine
no apology no no no
my bad i was tripping right right and i
just and i told him to right at the end
i was like most likely what happened
because i done it too is that you didn't
double confirm you booked the thing and
it didn't happen so that's why but i
booked it so i didn't kick you out you
didn't turn it on and you sat in a cold
song
so the best part is you keep mentioning
yeah it was a cool sign
so i go in there right
i'm sitting there and then for some
reason i started feeling bad because he
didn't get his sweat and so i walked i
opened up the door i was like would you
like to sit in with me as well oh you
invited him in i invited many girls so
whack bro
because no okay i'm good then i'm just
like hey you're so yeah i think you
handled that really well but that you're
you are a nice guy for asking him that's
a very polite yeah
did he kind of like smile a little bit
like
like he was trying to be mad and then
you asked him and he was like
no it's okay thanks man
he was kind of like boy about the thing
is he's like
how do you swing the door at somebody
and not expect to get sucked like i
think he's very lucky i'm like i'm not
i'm not just quick to just punch
somebody yeah exactly because you can't
just like
do that to somebody no
yeah i think it's just somebody people
he probably just hasn't been hit before
because like if like you have you
understand like you got to treat people
with a certain amount of respect or dude
might swing what it is i smile too much
man i knocked on that stupid glass door
and i was like hello
you know hey i made it in five minutes
thank you 1 15 to 2 o'clock as much
sorry i'm a little late it's 1 30 but
i'm here to use the sauna
i tipped off my
korean british [ __ ]
hey that is pretty you know what though
that is pretty nice of you you asked him
to come back in yeah i think you handled
that really well you're getting soft
david i think it's good hey two thousand
[ __ ]
twenty two twenty twenty twenty two
david is a new david bro i'm trying to
get two zero two two two zero two two
two
i think he handled that well but also
too like who knows maybe he just had a
bad day maybe he's just actually a dip
[ __ ] you know what i mean who knows and
he's over here working out in the gym
and still in a sauna suit she's an idiot
i want to see this guy how old is he i
think i saw him that day was he wearing
a gray hoodie
uh he was he was just in a i think it
was like a navy blue sonus but gilbert
saw him because he saw the guy in a
sauna suit working out because i saw
gilbert at the gym
gym etiquette don't go to the gym in a
sauna suit yeah what the [ __ ] because so
don't yell at me yeah yeah
yeah tall korean dudes bro you're going
to get paid that's shitty i just gotta
show up just in my boxing rooms
and just open the sauna door with the
boxing people are going to want to fight
you even more then yeah they probably
would have i don't got that heat for
them dude but that guy was [ __ ]
cruising for a bruise
what is it about the gym where dudes
like because i sometimes i catch people
looking at me kind of weird too and i'm
like what the [ __ ] i start getting mad
like what the [ __ ] is this dude like hey
[ __ ] the guy who grabs the 30 dumbbells
in the gym you know what i'm talking
about the guy that makes his own
bowflexes yes flexes
mr shoulders the [ __ ] the big black
dude the black mr clean he's missing he
actually works out shoulders i've only
ever seen him hit shoulders hey you see
how big his [ __ ] shoulders are though
yeah but like he literally died
every day who james harrison is he looks
like james harrison who's james harrison
the guy from the your friend no dude
jack harrison brick danger
the football player the steelers what is
it ernesto who still pushes he's pushing
a giant like thousand pound sled pushes
like he does that for reps and [ __ ] this
[ __ ] looks just like him let me
just tell you what this guy does so he
goes into you're scared of saying he
goes into the middle of the gym right
right where the pull-ups are in between
all the pulley machines yeah and he
stacks i [ __ ] you not
[ __ ] eight sets of dumbbells four j
men
all of them
five ten fifteen sweating his ass off on
everything i've never seen him wipe one
thing down ever
ever also lays down you know the back
pull bar like with the workout for the
rose he lays down on it like this sweat
yeah and he does these like this eye
pulls
more shoulders more shoulders
but you can just do that standing up
with other things like you don't have to
late like what's with the i hate when he
wants to lay down and work i hate when i
see dudes doing workouts you could do in
the traditional way yeah in an invert
like i've seen dudes like like a dude
bent over like he was getting [ __ ]
doggy style on that same thing and he
was doing like like tricep like why are
you doing that just stand up and do the
same thing you [ __ ] like you're not
making it cooler idiot this guy took
some of them are very honest dude the
funniest thing too is what i saw i saw
one of the
girls at the gym come up to him she goes
hey do you mind if i just take the five
pounds he goes no
needs five pounds like he he's five
pounds is not going to do anything for
him yeah he's he's so big this guy is so
strong i saw him today five pounds five
pounds five pounds it's a little like
the little the pulley machine the just
the one little bar why i just
sweating profusely his workouts how's it
getting at work shoulders i've never
never seen anything but shoulders yeah
only shoulders there's that same workout
routine and by the way lateral raises
somebody who works at the gym every day
for three hours should not look that
disgusting how about that yeah hey low
keto mr shoulders below below all that
fat on him i'm sure he's huge i do well
he is big
he always yeah he does always wear puffy
but i don't know why he only hit
shoulders he someone heard him bro
someone said to him like hey you got
like one of my buddies someone said
something uh she was a front desk girl
at the gym and she said to this dude
this podcast is brought to you by
uncommon goods if you haven't finished
your holiday shopping yet don't panic
we've got a secret source for incredible
original gif and that's uncommon goods
uncommongoods.com has the absolute best
gifts for everyone in your life so skip
the gifts that scream last minute and
find something truly
original at uncommon goods
at uncommongoods.com
yo
i'm getting some of the fellas this year
glass topper cocktail smokers that's on
uncommon goods and it's a dope gift
listen
all you people out there that give bad
gifts for the holidays like scratchy
sweaters cards with your ugly ass
children on it
you can all go to hell there's a special
place in hell for you mother efforts
okay give decent gifts go to uncommon
goods now to get 15 off your next gift
go to uncommongoods.combrain
that's
uncommongoods.com for 15 off don't miss
out on this limited time offer
uncommon goods we're all out of the
ordinary
oh your chest is kind of small whoa
every time i see him at the gym always
doing chest just
always always why say that to him what's
up tiny shoulders
shoulders tiny shoulders
that's why all your problems be hurting
you because all that weight on your
shoulders can't handle it
you got to get them stronger
that's how he has little shoulders yeah
yeah it's tiny little delts dude he
works out for our like hours at a time
he still looks like [ __ ] which is crazy
and he wears the mask nose out i like
that because when i do that now i'd i'll
just like that big motherfucker's doing
honestly
i don't wear a mask at the gym no more
bro i just i don't think
it doesn't matter and also if you if you
were in my area like i stay six feet
away from everyone oh you'll see one guy
that's very particular about it there's
one dude at the gym that asked me i put
my mask on my nose he goes can you make
sure to put your mask on fully does he
work there uh no is he a police officer
absolutely arrest me then she's like
[ __ ] off yeah i heard a lady say that i
was in another room she's like can you
please put your mask up i'm like suck my
balls dude
[ __ ] you lady mind your business
you're gonna die anyways
for sure
sooner than me
knocking at your door
give it up already
no point in the gym you're leaving god's
earth anyway
in a [ __ ] body bag lady
damn you wild bro dude [ __ ] that that's
just annoying like what the guy i mean
the guy who told me to do it like i
remember like my internal thing was like
technically this goes right
she wasn't even talking to me that's the
thing i just got mad as if she was you
just lost her i just got angry like who
are you talking to i don't know i didn't
even see i was literally in another room
i just heard her voice and it pissed me
off i just continued the workout but i
started working out closer to the guy
and every rep you take one step
i was doing curls and then he was doing
the uh the shoulder press the free
weight shoulder press the bench
he made the comment as i was in front of
him so i just moved next to him and i
just started doing curls
hey you how effective you think these
masks are huh
they get all the molecules
it was pretty passive aggressive yeah
but i just because technically he's
right so i can't say anything yeah but
it's just a really [ __ ] thing to do
it's like number one guy i'm not even
facing towards you like he's behind me
and i'm like clearly like 10 feet away
from him but he saw my face through the
mirror that i had the [ __ ] mask
beneath my nose well it's just annoying
like like the nose is too much
that's one thing but if it's under the
nose come on no even if i see dudes like
this it's not my business you live your
life how the [ __ ] you want to live your
life like it to be like this little
police to other dude like that's [ __ ]
annoying
that's dry snitching that's annoying
[ __ ] that's annoying i should have told
him that why don't you tell your [ __ ]
mom [ __ ] yeah yeah whole monitor and
you just
what is that you're a hall monitor yeah
yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] bro yeah what about
yours go write me up right this up right
here yeah like what is the fanny pack
hey
i don't know but i was i was hitting the
bag in the kickboxing area there's a
dude cycling he had no mask on i was
fine with it yeah yeah yeah and the guy
everyone's vaccinated here
bro you're like 10 feet away from that
room is known
away yeah it's a no mass room also 10
feet away everyone's vaccinated most
likely you know or you had covered also
shut the [ __ ] up yeah yeah
most important yeah most important shut
the [ __ ] up he's like don't worry i'm
backstage i was like honestly bro you're
like 10 feet away from me you're on the
[ __ ] bike your face the other way you
don't have to explain yourself just
yeah because i'm not going to hit that
bag with a mask on it
impossible i'll literally throw up it's
impossible there's just certain things
you just can't wear a mask too and
that's one of them hitting the bag doing
cardio i heard some lady got mad at this
uh the guy who looks like the guy from
the mummy the guy with the eyebrows
brendan frazier oh yeah yeah yeah the
mummy guy himself yeah the mummy ball
guy yeah he was he was on the treadmill
and he had his mask off
everyone says he's really nice i haven't
met him yet but apparently he's always
talking about food and stuff
i was here talking about his meal plan
this old white lady went up to him and
was like you need to put your mask on oh
and he's like
stop like i'm just on the trail i'm
sorry i'm just on a treadmill
nobody he would nobody was around him
like he was by himself he was that's
annoying that's he was like
yeah but you know i'm also kind of dying
here like he's one of those guys
actually trains like he's like trains
hard yeah he does so it's like just let
him [ __ ] what lady you're not even
anywhere near him i just was right over
there too yeah to just the weirdest
thing it's like yeah exactly you came
all the way over here to come into my
coveted vicinity yeah why would you do
that [ __ ] that doesn't even make sense
i would just look at her straight in her
[ __ ] dead eyes and be like listen i
don't even [ __ ] wrap my dick when i
go raw yeah so shut up [ __ ] up how about
that also hey yes pat says die yeah
it's the same lady i got it
you want it too
get away
dude no yeah that's obviously [ __ ]
people like it's just the snitching [ __ ]
because we all know bro it's like look
bro i think everybody
across the world across the nation is
just like yeah i'm sick of massively how
come we just can't treat people with
decency we can't agree that matt like
some of them like we don't want to wear
masks all the time
yeah you gotta wear it you know at the
same time
also don't go to a gym yeah don't go to
the gym stay inside if you're that
worried number one two also people just
don't mind their own [ __ ] business
but you wanna just mind your [ __ ]
business and uh like you do what the
[ __ ] you wanna do leave me a [ __ ]
loan
the person that goes up to emote
and [ __ ] tells them to put a mask on
she don't really care she does yeah she
don't care you know i mean like if you
really do care you'd be like i'm not
going anywhere in that [ __ ] like
that's how you handle it right i don't
have copic but i have aids which one
you're worried about yeah i feel like
[ __ ]
that's it damn needle i'm a lick it i
must [ __ ] stick
i'm sure there's a chance yeah
that's enough to worry though roughly a
quarter i'll keep you up at night dogs i
wouldn't be thinking about it yeah
because i saw it you're like i gotta get
checkmates oh [ __ ] one of the most
obnoxious things that was on [ __ ] uh
youtube stories right so you know
no no no so
uh
people will kind of put up certain
content to
kind of ride like some type of sjw wave
right
well
people are getting a little hip to that
[ __ ] and they're ripping them a new one
that's right so there was a clip of a
girl with
one of the most succulent booties i've
ever seen and she was wearing the tights
that
to the point where it's not just tights
it's the stretchy ones that goes
literally in the ass so you see every
cro
so if it wasn't for the fabric you would
think she was naked yeah you could see
the vagina and the women
that's crazy
i gotta tell you this thank you it's
fantastic it's nice i love it it's but
every girl's not every every girl knows
and i and i asked all the homegirls it's
like hey when the girl wears that stuff
do they know what they're doing she goes
of course they [ __ ] know what they're
doing he's like i have tights honestly
you're a [ __ ] yeah
i have tights all the time i don't need
to wear that that specific type of type
like you have to really shove that [ __ ]
in your ass for it to be that way
because i didn't think it was oh you
have to like put it up there like it's a
very specific it's not like how it fits
no no you you put that in your ass like
you make it form that way sure oh i see
so it's like oh
your ass whole like it's uncomfortable
yeah and i'm pretty sure there's ones
that you don't but i'm not i don't know
i asked a few girlfriends before i
should try so we should do a try-on
let's try it let's try it let's start
with you [ __ ]
you're gonna see why this will gotta
dump on you yeah i'm a girl
like a little bit dude
in the video she's doing she's racking
up a couple of weights and a guy comes
over to her it's like hey you want me to
spot you but in her caption she wrote i
felt uncomfortable basically calling
this guy a creep and this dude in the
most normal way he was like is it gonna
are you putting up the weights up or
down right oh i see yeah and then he was
just simple and he just walked away
and he goes okay cool and then she just
basically calls this guy a [ __ ]
pervert and a creep but his interaction
was hella normal he was trying to help
her put it on top yeah he was like
asking oh like do you need it up or down
and then she was like no i'm good he
goes okay cool and he just walks away
yeah he wasn't looking at her anyway and
he just kind of walked up and she called
this guy a [ __ ] pervert this girl got
ripped in the car of course like yo what
the [ __ ]
yeah and by the way the people that were
ripping or were majority women they're
like first of all
we know those type of tights that you're
wearing and you have to wear it
specifically because you're video you're
filming yourself from behind and so we
know what you're doing you're thirst
trapping online yeah and then you have a
guy who just walks up asks you about
your weight and then you automatically
assume that he's being a pervert yeah
you set him up like why did you set this
guy up and also there's way bigger
offenses that go in the gym if you're a
girl and some weird guy comes up to you
like i see that [ __ ] all the time at the
gym yeah i see weirdos like trying to
talk to girls and i feel bad because
these poor girls are like really trying
to train and do their own workout
and like these guys are like always
trying to like bro [ __ ] lingerers dog
they hang around they ask like these
[ __ ] nebulous questions to these
people
and they're just trying they're trying
to work out you know they don't have a
conversation and they're asking
like the lamest questions the worst
that would be more [ __ ] interesting
than what these guys saying hey tesla
right no excuse me this is
i mean some girls can write in the
comments below right if they agree when
you wear those tights
i'm very grateful for it i'll tell you
this they're probably the best thing
that has ever happened in my lifetime
mankind fantastic right
but when you wear it do you wear it
knowing that people are going to like
guys who are heterosexual males are
going to stare or do you expect guys not
to look because i got to tell you
make signals though
well yeah i mean of course i wear
sunglasses in the gym now
he's just like by still grabbing the ass
with the dumbbell machine
so squishy today
dumbbells 100 so embarrassing i'm
wearing sunglasses i literally pretend
i'm blind and i now i'm the blind guy in
the gym like wow this blind guy could
really hit the bag
he's good this is the next one he's like
off center's not pushing anything that's
a daredevil dude
perfect
the room is all red and black too
just bone or just some fat burner the
whole time
do you have a boner it's my walking
stick
[ __ ]
you like bullying the blind [ __ ]
excuse me as i grab her breast and i
push her away bro you got to know cause
i mean because dudes do the same thing
like guys like if you're like a ripped
ass dude and you you go you you walk in
you know you you can wear like shirts
that are more like fit your [ __ ] where
the back shirts ever even
work
even at like work or like or you know if
you like go around a bunch of gay dudes
and you wear like [ __ ] tank top
shorts like you're gonna get checked out
like come on now you know that as a dude
i know that right so you know you look
good in them pants yeah dog are you why
do you also check me you check you out
at any doesn't matter what you got on
all i do i what i do real quick is that
i pretend like i'm lifting weights i get
a quick weight
i get little weights see i don't even
work i don't know what they're
i called just hit the saddle i don't
know what they're called at all hey let
me get that weight right there
excuse me you know the the weight the 25
pound weight i started doing this
the thing that looks like yeah this
thing right past the wall
past that while you know where you're at
fat boy [ __ ] yeah the weight just give
me a weight dude give me the weight dog
just give me a little weight [ __ ] me
give me the weight
that's actually a better name
i just mispronounced everything yeah i
just want some bicep worlds bro it's
crazy
i just grab the dumbbells here i lift up
and i move my elbows back
nice i have a [ __ ] weight loss bet
dude by february 1st i have to drop down
officially
25 more pounds where you at right uh oh
25. so i started at 2 30 when i came
back from hawaii i'm i'm 220 right now
let's go
25 by february you said 25 pounds hey
let me tell you something i jogged for
the first time yesterday one of the most
painful experiences talking about bro do
the bike do the bike you know what the
bike the bike's really fun but then
what i noticed about um jogging versus
doing um like the stationary bike or
even just biking in general is that
uh jogging helps tighten up my core so
it's kind of like a what two in one go
yeah so uh
it just hits things a little different
like the obliques like my [ __ ]
obliques are sore dude because you're
just stabilizing and you're just doing
this the whole time you just stabilize
that core plus i heard this one [ __ ]
phrase yesterday that [ __ ] got me in
my heart strings like discipline is
discipline isn't doing things that you
like
this podcast is brought to you by better
help my friends if you haven't focused
on your mental health this year now is
the time to start listen we've all been
cooped up tense and honestly we know the
importance of our mental health so let's
stop pushing our thoughts and emotions
aside and keep telling us that we don't
need this because you do because i did
too and you might be like me better help
will assess your needs and match you
with your own licensed professional
therapist you don't have to sit at an
uncomfortable waiting room and you can
message your counselor at any time while
setting up weekly video or phone
sessions it's super convenient and more
importantly it allows you to be in your
own safe and comfortable environment
listen i've used better help and it was
a great experience i still use it till
this day so i'm about where my mouth is
my friends i put my money where my mouth
is and that's what's up special offer
for genius brain listeners get 10 off
your first month at betterhelp.com
genius so visit betterhelp.com
genius to get that 10 off and work on
that mental health baby
yeah how long do you go drive for
two miles man and then yeah you stopped
you know i do about a mile right now
that's good
well it's a solid start it's hard to do
it all the way because you get bored
it's not even the pain
yeah it's boring you got a step counter
uh yeah i do pacer the app not sponsored
get that step counter bro get that
[ __ ] 10 to 15k a day
should i do 10k in general because i do
uh if i'm not jogging i just walk around
you know i'd be walking off yeah
you're a walking man but you hit 15k
it's true you know what it is it's the
food the calorie counting thing that's
the hardest it's just managing how much
i eat yeah and it always [ __ ] kills
me because apparently everything's a
thousand calories dude like what
everything dude [ __ ] food
that's
everywhere
everything that's delicious is a
thousand calories
it's all the it's all the combos of the
oils and the fat and the carbs that's
what makes it good right that's what it
is since you're a fitness person what is
your what is the biggest advice that you
would give somebody to help them to
start losing weight man
for most people right it depends because
it's a sp i'm a client okay i'll be the
client all right
okay that's a fact
i was like oh geez that way the voice is
heavy so my partner patrick
we've been [ __ ] for years now yeah
yeah you have and now he's telling me
it's hard to put me on my knees
and just ram me consistently so i'm
trying to make sure i lose some dump if
i can get a client if i can get a client
that is this up front with me in the
beginning we could conquer the world
that's the best 100 we can conquer the
world this can be easy for you to hit
those gains yeah most people are not
that open and now i'm trying i'm
220 pounds and i need to get down to 190
to fix my relationship with patty p
call him patty p peace for penis penis
penis just made up just in case you
didn't know
so
what do i do
or bro
i'm depressed
well look
it's a tough question because a lot of
people it really depends on where you're
at
like for most people yeah if you don't
exercise
at all and you are trying to lose a
bunch of weight i would say the best
thing you do is just try to get your
daily activity a little bit higher for
the most part go on more walks staying
more active because that's like you got
to meet people where they're at because
at the end of the day dude like when it
comes to fitness or anything
it really comes down to your habits and
what you're going to be able to
reproduce day in and day out so for a
lot of times it's a momentum game you
have to kind of just build small
easy things like going on a walks every
day giving people a step count of like
say you walk the american average is
3000 steps a day if you were to bump
that up to 8 000 or 7 000 which is not
that unreasonable for a sustained period
of time you're going to see some pretty
good results on top of while you're
fixing
your nutritional habits wherever that
may be for you say you drink a soda with
every [ __ ] meal you take that out
three meals a day
that's like four 300 to 400 calories you
take that out that's gonna be enough to
put you to deficit for a same period of
time until that's all you have to do so
wherever you're at you kind of want to
start a little bit lower from what you
think you can do
then because you kind of want to start
at a way more um base level you can't
you can't try to change the world
because then you're going to get [ __ ]
yeah i think the hard part is to like
i think we're we're kind of in a world
now where we want everybody to just make
you feel okay about everything right
yeah and so you know i've always stated
this before too and if you guys haven't
known who i am i was a very large guy so
it's like this rhetoric of people just
saying like
i understand like if somebody's fat
don't go out your way to call them
[ __ ] fat yeah leave them the [ __ ]
alone
don't be a dick that's so wild yeah yeah
if you're [ __ ] fat yeah [ __ ]
it's like okay for example
like there's these videos online on
facebook and youtube that are super
popular this is one like indian director
that creates these like fat shaming no
they create these videos that
they're not supposed to be funny but
they're some of the funniest videos i've
ever seen in my life and it's trying to
teach morality to people yeah but they
kind of do these these uh short films
that are eight minutes long but they
shoot them like christian infomercials
right so it'll be like some like the
video that i saw was um
a little person gets bullied right and
it's treating you that you shouldn't
treat little people any differently but
it's this little person that wants to be
a bodybuilder and he's getting punked in
a gym but the situation is the most
unrealistic thing you've ever seen in
your life like the dude the guy who's a
little person is actually the guy who
was in logan paul's camp
really yeah and so he has a little
person in his camp yeah um
i don't remember his name but he was
really he's pretty popular you could
follow his instagram but
they're all actors
he's just working out somebody goes well
look at the little squirt
whoa big little guy call them big
weights
the guy's like why don't you leave me
alone you know
like this is not real this doesn't
happen nobody just walks up to a little
person that's lifting weights and goes
hey look at this little tiny thing he
hopped onto that box he's an athlete
like [ __ ] amazing and then they i'm
like when have you ever seen somebody in
a gym come up to a little person and
just go what's up you look like a pimple
[ __ ] yeah yeah like one of the dishes
was that look at those biceps look at
those two little pimples
and so and they're rude that is rude
and and so
there's a gym owner in the video
and he's like an older guy and he used
to be a bodybuilder and he goes you know
what
he's going to enter a bodybuilding
competition he goes i'm going to train
you he goes you know why i started
getting buff and it goes into a
flashback of him looking at another buff
guy talking to a girl and he goes that's
going to be me he starts jogging away
then at the end of the thing this is the
funniest part
he loses he gets second place to the
douche bag that was making fun of him
right now wow
and then but then a gymshark
representative comes up to him and he
goes you know what
i want you to represent jim shark he
goes as a little person he goes no as a
regular athlete gives him a 25 000 check
wow
funniest part ever out of nowhere he
whips out his phone he goes i like to
pay off my friend's debt
and so he's paying off the gym the gym
trainer's debt i was like first of all
the guy that was being mean to him first
of all you didn't call anybody you just
picked up the phone and said i like the
calls
his iphone's working he just picks up
the phone and says i like to pay off his
debt
it's like santa suit guy dude they just
don't understand how [ __ ] works
how does he know where the loan is too
you know what i mean like how does he
know who does he call it which bank does
he call what he calls he has his
information on hand and then the guy was
just so moved by it he was like yeah i
just wanna i just wanted to see that
sketch where he calls the guy and the
person's like who the [ __ ] is this
yeah who's death this is papa john's
this is papa john's dog what pizza would
you like and also or not
what do you guys know whose friend he's
talking about he doesn't know the [ __ ]
this guy is no [ __ ] idea where do you
find these videos wait where did you see
this so that's what i was thinking
like a friend of mine sent it and then
he just didn't say anything at all
and i started busting up laughing
because you're laughing aren't you and
i'm like yeah i am he goes so am i i
just wanted to make sure i'm not going
to hell because it's just the funniest
[ __ ] thing ever and they have another
they have multiple videos they have a
series it's like a campaign or something
what is this it's it's online i'm
supposed to teach you morality but i
thought it was like an snl parody yeah
it's a legit video trying to and it has
millions of views that's crazy and
people are moved by it they're like this
is exactly what i needed to see
oh [ __ ] out all the little people out
there don't want to be bodybuilders you
know it's the weirdest
big demo
but they had that they had another one
where a girl who was um it's a true
story it's this girl who's like um
scientifically speaking she's obese and
she's a ballerina and this is legit she
has like hundreds of thousands of
followers on instagram but they decided
to do a sketch about how not to judge a
book by its cover
great moral her her story in itself is
already good but he decided to write a
[ __ ] uh lifetime
short for her they just made it worse
yes they trying to do too much she's in
painting a picture she's in a store
where there's ballerina outfits right
she's a larger girl and of course the
person who's selling her the stuff walks
up to her she goes hi do you need any
help she goes i'm looking for a leotard
she goes
you know it's for ballerinas right cause
she's fat yeah [ __ ] hippo
dude what the [ __ ] with a lisp so you
crazy ladies uh when have you ever seen
anybody who's trying to make a living
yeah you
yeah i'm a ballerina she goes
ew
yeah okay i'll be right back fatty
walks off we'll see what we have in the
back yeah yeah speaking of back look how
huge you're is that [ __ ]
but the girls just starts crying wow
this is not this is just the most
exaggeration of like making humanity
seem worse than it actually is yeah
right not a single time have i ever seen
that in my whole existence of living as
a fat person when i was trying on a suit
somebody just walked up to me like hey
once you burst out of those seams you
fat [ __ ]
nobody has ever walked up to me when i
was in a macy's trying on a suit
nice wetsuit fatty
[Laughter]
it would have been good if the guy from
men's warehouse said that to you
are you gonna sell a suit when you can't
fit it you idiot
but you're gonna like the way you look
but you're gonna light the way you look
if you could fit it you fat [ __ ]
and i started crying as i was helping
people out selling suits it's just the
most ridiculous thing i've ever seen man
but like people keep doing this are they
all indian actors no these are all
american actors they don't want to see
these videos yeah i gotta we gotta watch
we'll watch it after this [ __ ] you'll
[ __ ] do it yeah i gotta see some
after school special [ __ ] yeah what is
this
[ __ ] infomercial
doug it's the most ridiculous if you
guys have time i know some of you are
going to watch this and you're going to
think i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] does it have
bro that's hilarious does it have like
that little filter of like yeah like the
god kind of hazy yeah yeah
yeah you know what i'm talking about
like
like goosebumps and [ __ ]
had that wishbone had that what's the
story wishbone it's
it's so
this one
is that it has 25 million views and then
people are moved by this i'm like how
how are you moved by this it's the
common man yo and people are telling
their own stories like yeah i walked
into the store and i could tell people
didn't want me there it's like well
first of all did they actually walk up
to you and go shamu
all right
whoa look this isn't a hot dog i like
that one whoa
behind
yeah the worst thing that has ever
happened to me was when i was in my
parents store and then a little girl
came up to me she rubbed my belly and
she was like my mommy's pregnant too
that's something yeah
that's more realistic that's realistic
because this kid doesn't know about she
doesn't know kids and people that are
close to you are way more likely to say
some worst [ __ ] oh you're a [ __ ]
attendant at foot locker you know yeah
like they would never say some [ __ ] like
that yeah i sucked that little kid and
we were good after too yeah what's up
[ __ ] the [ __ ]
put you back in your mom's [ __ ]
i said yeah
well guys that wraps up this episode of
the genius brain podcast
you can follow nick at nick the ear for
all your fitness needs
nick has been helping people get on the
right track to fitness and life that
sounds so sarcastic
four years
four years
he was the original guy that was calling
people fat [ __ ] retail stores for
sure 100 percent turn into a business so
you know holler at me good for you
yeah good for you what's the size of
your belt planet you fat [ __ ]
here's my car
[Laughter]
i can say these jokes i'm still fat
when i lose the weight no longer but for
now i can still make fat jokes and then
you can find patrick at patrick.t riley
he's making fun of fat people all the
time all the time that's his job gotta
do it every day dude this will just
stick snickers in people's pants like
you're gonna need this for later
i say these jokes because these are
jokes that have been sent to me
and that's pat for you guys yeah yeah
follow them see what he's gonna do his
next stand-up show and then bop
see you all next time
peace